with a skip and a salute one of
hollywood's most successful actors
arriving for perhaps the most important
performance of his life
with 150 million dollars in damages on
the line johnny depp told his side of
the story
but never
did i myself
reach the point of
striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
in my life
depp said allegations he is a domestic
abuser are lies invoking the fairy tales
and it's been six years of
trying times
it's very
strange when
one day your
[Music]
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds you're
quasimodo
under the steely stare of his former
wife depp acted out the point that women
can be the primary abuser
my mother was
quite unpredictable
she was very unpredictable
um she was a
she had the ability to be
as as cruel as
anyone can be
he spoke in detail about his own mom
betty sue being violent to her husband
and children including a young death
shield yourself because you didn't know
what was going to happen
much of this trial is he said she said
it's been an unedifying portrait of a
volatile relationship but with the
actors paul bettany and james franco
also listed as potential witnesses
alongside the tech billionaire elon musk
it is a case which will continue to
captivate
six years after johnny depp and amber
heard divorced the ruins of their
relationship continue to be picked over
in a courtroom whichever way this
seven-person jury sides both will be
diminished by the battle martha kellner
sky news virginia